monkey pox has become
it's become the anti-covet
it's become
the way that the libs forced us all to
live under covid which was very very
easily spread
and did not really pose major major
health risks to the vast majority of
people but it was still very very easy
to spray it was so easy to spread that
you pretty much couldn't stop it from
spreading there was no measure that the
libs employed from the masks to the
lockdowns to the distance by six feet to
the shots to the boosters none of that
has actually worked to stop kovid at all
not even in the slightest and yet they
made it shut down our lives for two
years then monkey pox
which can be a little bit more dangerous
but is not very easily spread there's
pretty much only one way to spread it
and it's not very pleasant at least in
the minds of the vast majority of people
the monkey pox which is only i know this
is politically incorrect to say it's
pretty much only spread
at gay orgies not even at any orgy
though every orgy is in a certain sense
gay but specifically at male
homosexual
bath house style orgies that's where it
started the spread and that's where it
continues to spread
those we can't shut down now we can't we
can't even acknowledge it ned ryan who's
a conservative
uh activist a sort of prominent
conservative figure he just went on a
fox business show the kennedy show
where it was him two other panelists and
the host kennedy and they were
discussing monkey pox and he suggested
maybe maybe people cool it with the gay
orgies for just a little bit
all three other people on screen
jump down his throat for it
as for monkey pox i think there's a
pretty good rule in life
uh don't attend gay orgies uh when you
look at the new england journals report
of the fight how about anybody
ned come on man it's not about gay how
about not anywhere
go look at the new england journals
report that nbc news reported on on
friday in which of the 528 cases they
reviewed 95 percent
were between sex between men i think we
actually have to have a certain
instead of going crazy and declaring a
national pandemic when 3 000 people have
it right now it's insane
i don't know man you don't have to be
gay to get monkey pox and
you don't have to be
bigoted when you talk about treating
something that is that easily spread
it's not big yeah it is this is science
kennedy 95 percent of the cases from the
numerator
respond okay that kind of i will use the
term bigoted language that makes it seem
like the only people that get this are
from one group of americans hey guess
what gay men also have friends and
family members and colleagues and this
is not just transmitted through sexual
activity so
everything that ned ryan said is right
virtually everyone who is catching
monkey pox is catching monkey pucks
because they had sex with a promiscuous
gay man
95 to 98 of the spread is among
dudes who have sex with other dudes the
men who have sex with men community as
some people are calling it and then some
people around them are catching monkey
pox as well which raises a whole lot of
questions you know there were two kids
who caught monkey pox in households with
homosexual men
haven't heard anything about that sure
hope that's being investigated but i i
doubt that it is
what ned ryan said is right and by the
way if you want to prevent people from
catching monkey pox if you if you care
about the homosexuals who are at risk of
getting monkey pox which is specifically
homosexuals who
are getting frisky with lots and lots of
other homosexuals in promiscuous sex and
orgies
you would want this information to be
out there you'd want people to know the
risks right so he just
reads a news report from a left-wing
source about from a medical journal
and the three people on screen say
that's bigoted
those are hate facts
those are first you heard from brad
palumbo who is an lgbt activist and he's
i guess he's a liberty he would call
himself a libertarian and but he's very
very pro lgbt and he says oh ned you
can't say that it's any orgies it's
don't say gay origins but no it is
specifically it is gay orgies that
spreads monkey pox it's just a fact okay
it's just numbers 95 to 98 guys
okay
that's
no you can't say that and then
palumbo was far from the worst person on
that panel then it was the host kennedy
and the other guest whose name i believe
is marie harf who called it bigoted
don't go to gay orgies is now considered
a bigoted statement
on on the right wing news channel on one
of what two or three right-wing news
channels fox business is probably the
second most prominent right-wing news
chat allegedly right-wing news channel
and you can't say don't go to gay orgies
there or you knuckle dragging right far
right fascist bigoted drugledite how
dare you
gay orgies is what america was built on
that's how dare you discriminate against
the gay orgy community
these are the sorts of things that can't
be uttered now
it shows you the way that the overton
window has shifted
when when libs tell you oh no the
conservatives are on the rise the
conservatives have made so many cultural
gains in recent years just look at that
overton window look at the range of
acceptable discourse you can no longer
go on a an ostensibly right-wing news
network and say hey don't go to gay
orgies maybe if you don't want to catch
the gay orgy pox virus
and you you can't say that
without being smeared as a bigot
as some kind of hateful awful person
because you recite statistics that were
just published in a medical journal
that is the cultural shift yes cons i
think conservatives have great
opportunities right now we just
overruled roe v wade for goodness sakes
this is great i think the wind is at our
sails
but the ground that we have to make up
is so insane the one that the liberals
are losing their minds over right now is
that conservatives might threaten this
new definition of marriage
the obergefell decision which redefined
marriage to include
same-sex unions
the idea that that would be the great
conservative cultural victory is insane
guys that that decision was made in 2015
that decision is seven years old
for all of human history up until 2015
everyone everywhere believed that
marriage had sexual difference at its
heart
that marriage was between a man and a
woman
the idea that we would return to that
and this would be the huge far right
fascistic
authoritarian return to 2014
are you kidding me think about how much
ground
we have lost
you realize how much ground we've lost
not even when you watch the far right
news channels it's when you watch the
news channels that are supposed to be
conservative you realize just how far
left the culture has become
this
this sort of monkey pox media reaction
is a true
lesson
in in
political hierarchies who ranks above
whom whose rights get protected above
others during covet if you wanted to
visit your dying parents let's say they
were in a hospital or they were in a
nursing home they were just just kind of
aged you were not allowed to do that
when when your loved ones did die you
were not allowed to bury them you were
not allowed to have a funeral for them
for months or
years
george floyd was allowed to have four
funerals but you you were not allowed to
have funerals for your family members
you were not allowed to go to church you
were not allowed to go to work you were
not allowed to open your business in a
lot of places you were not allowed to do
much of anything
the pot dispensaries in california those
stayed open that was kind of weird
churches were closed but the pot
dispensaries were open okay that kind of
show that gave you a little inkling huh
maybe this isn't just about what's safe
and what's healthy maybe this is about
the political preferences of the ruling
elite maybe this was about giving
special privileges to certain groups and
discriminating against other groups
and then monkey pox shows it for certain
we shut down the entire world for for
over two years
certainly you shut down the country
for a cough that was unpreventable
but you won't even shut down the gay
bath houses to stop the gay bath house
virus
you won't stop it you won't do it
you you're not even allowed to mention
it
even on
a a conservative ostensibly conservative
news channel right now go to
epicwill.com use code knowles for all
you adventurous spirits out there did
you know here's a fun fact 100 of people
who skydive will die
100
100 of people who breathe
also will die whatever you do however
you try to avoid it
you will die no one here gets out alive
and you've got to make sure that you
take care of your sweet little beautiful
babies your kids you got to make sure
you take care of the people who love you
and you got to make those important
decisions about what's going to happen
to you and all your stuff and to your
family so that your loved ones aren't
stuck in a lurch when you finally kick
the bucket a will is not even primarily
about you it's about all those loved
ones and the hard decisions they are
going to face
when something happens to you i won't
even say if because it is inevitable my
friends sorry that this is a little bit
of a downer but that's how it goes
that's why you got to go to epic will
get your whole will sorted out you can
do it it's very very quick it's
extremely inexpensive if you go to epic
will use promo code knowles k-w-l-e-s
you will save ten percent on epic will's
complete will package they'll set you up
with a will in as little as five minutes
it's it's about 119
to secure your family's future
unbelievable deal without a will
you're gonna hand your stuff and your
money over to people who don't like you
very much i'm talking about the
government talking about all sorts of
bad folks don't do it go to epicwill.com
use code knowles today i'm so glad you
liked that clip now
you gotta ring that bell we hit a
million subscribers right before the
birth of my second baby how great is
that what a great birthday gift for him
great father's day gift for me
you can tell i haven't slept in days
make sure you ring that bell subscribe
let's get up to 10 million let's get up
to 1 billion subscribers here on this
platform we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]